[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today hi Jenny
welcome to the ramsy show hi thanks for
having me sure how can we
help uh my husband and I are on baby set
two and we are all in I've got a second
job he's working overtime we're selling
everything but our kid um we're all in
good however um we are looking at
anywhere depending on what option pick
at the dentist we're looking at anywhere
from $10 to $50,000 worth of work needed
on my husband's
teeth um I don't know how to do that
without taking on more
debt what's your household
income
170 well I do you save up
$10,000 well okay so the
$10,000 um gets us 10 years they said
and then he probably have to have the
work done again do you still think
that's the best option or should we wait
or should we try to do the $50,000
option which is a fix for the rest of
his
life
um B or C none of the above I want you
to go I want you to go talk to two other
dentists okay I'm calling
BS okay unless your husband has some
kind of
disease
50,000 is out of control
I not a medical professional implants
it's for dental implants I know but it's
not okay then it's not 50 Grand let's go
shopping let's go shopping okay okay
okay um because the the thing I I I
don't know beans about being a dentist
okay uh but what I do know from having
sat in this chair for 30 years is that
I've had a lot of people bring me
dramatic numbers like you just did and I
send them back to the marketplace and
they there's a lot of other ways to do
this and turns out and a lot of uh
different pricing structures and so
forth for some reason when it comes to
medical or dental or things like this we
we don't shop like we if if you were
buying a car and someone said you could
buy a $50,000 car or a $10,000 car you
would say okay uh tell me about it and
and and then I'm going to keep looking
at cars I'm going to keep shopping and
then I'm going to have a lot of things
to compare with not just two of these
options so but for some reason all of us
you included uh just accept well it's
50,000 bucks Dennis said so um doc said
it's this and no there's a you
know vast array of pricing structures in
that world so I want to go shopping and
then yes I'll put let's pretend you can
fix this for 10 or 15,000 bucks or
20,000 bucks even okay for implants okay
something more permanent and you don't
have to cheap out but you also don't
have to go bananas okay so
um then then the answer to your question
is how do you pull that off you make 170
you just just slow your dead snowball
and pile up 20 grand depending on the
urgency the amount of pain he's in or
whatever it is you're facing is how fast
you do it uh if it's me and I'm hurting
we're going to do it fast cuz I'm a
complete wuss you want it over with
quickly I I I don't do pain I'm a wuss
Sharon has the pain tolerance of a Navy
SEAL uh I get a hang nail and I'm in the
floor crying like a four-year-old so no
I mean so I'm going to go I'm going to
write some checks yeah and get out of
pain is what I'm going to do
but anyway so just depending on the
urgency of the situation and if if what
she's saying is true let's say 10,000
buys are 10 years well 10 years from now
you're going to be in a very different
place financially in two years it might
be debt free and you could do whatever
you want I don't know if I want to rent
my teeth for 10 years but anyway I'm
confus I didn't know it was like an HVAC
like well this thing will keep it
running for the next 10 years I don't
know what they're doing to his mouth
there it's a very
strange well diagnosis I I can tell you
this there's
um the cost it's $400 and something, to
become a dentist now and then buying
into a practice would be another half
million or so and so there's a
whole business side of
Dentistry that allows them to
sell a vast array of products I've
fallen for it every time I go in there
they have a new technology they've
purchased that can now do this new thing
and it's for $50 a tooth we can do this
for you otherwise it'll be 300 later on
if you get the cavity and I'm like I
don't it's so stressful that's called
practice
management sometimes sales which is
medical talk for sales okay so um I I
I'm not accusing this dentist of
malpractice I'm just saying he's willing
to sell implants are the most will to
sell oenia Bentley that's all I'm saying
I'm seeing on Google Dave one to $1 to
$5,000 per implanted tooth is what the
going rate is so if he's talking many
many teeth could be 50 Grand it could be
okay depending all right Google we know
Google's right always right I go go to
WebMD for all of my health needs yeah
yeah if you go to WebMD you're dying you
have three days to live that's it you
got three days to live everything is
three days to live or it's a minor head
cold three days to live and $1,000 a
tooth yeah three days to live yeah I I
seriously shop it Jenny that's what I
would do and then if you need 20,000
bucks slow down your you got 170 coming
in slow down your de snowball enough at
the speed of the urgency to come up with
the 20K if you're going to wait 10
months that' be $2,000 a month we're
going to do it over 10 months if we need
to do it right now we're going to have
to stop everything and do it over 2 or 3
months right and so uh however quick you
can build up the 20K but it is going to
impact and slow down your debt snowball
speed because this is something you have
to deal with your your
husband's uh dental health does matter
and we're not we're not blowing that off
create your free every dollar budget
today the simplest way to budget for
your life